لازم تشيرين محمدي بيتها بعد قرار الحكومه
الافغانيه منعها وقريناتها من العمل شيرين
كانت تعمل في منظمه المعونه الافغانيه
البريطانيه منذ سنوات عده وها هي اليوم
تفقد مورد رزقها على غرار العديد من
النسوه
اشعر بخيبه امل قبيل اسقاط الجمهوريه
قالوا لنا ان طالبان تغيرت لم ارى اي
تغيير او تطور انا محجبه لكن لا املك الان
الا البكاء القرار الذي جاء عبر بيان
لوزاره الاقتصاد لم يكتفي بمنع عمل النساء
بل ارسل تحذيرا للمؤسسات الاجنبيه غير
الحكوميه والمحليه
بسحب تراخيصها ان لم تنفذ القرار حركه
طالبا احجمت عن التعليق على القرار او
الخوض في حيثياته
احب ان ابين لكم ان هذه المؤسسات لم تلتزم
بمناشيره وبقرارات الحكومه بعدم الاختلاط
بين الجنسين في همم في المؤسسات
الدوليه وغير الدوليه والمحليه بحيث
يوفروا
لطبقه همم الاناث يعني مكاتب خاصه بدهن
بحيث لا يكون الاختلاط بين الرجال والنساء
في تلك المواسات قرار جاء بعد يومين فقط
من منع فتيات افغانيات من التعلم في
الجامعات الحكوميه والخاصه وما زالت
تداعياته تتفاعل في الشارع
الافغانيم
ومن حقنا ان نتعلم وطالب الحكومه بالتراجع
عن قرارها وان تسمح بسنت دراسه وعمل
المراه
وقد شهدت مدن افغانيه عده حقن دهار وجلال
اباد وهيروت مظاهرات احتجاج على قرار منع
عمل النساء واجهتها قوات الامن باطلاق
الرصاص ورش المياه على المتظاهرين بينما
تشير مصادر امميه الى وقف اربع منظمات
دوليه عملها في افغانستان
اعتراضا على القرارات الاخيره بعد اغلاق
الجامعات في وجه الفتيات وحضر عمل النساء
تصاعدت الاذنات محليا ودوليا لقرارات
طالبا في مؤشر من شانه ان يعمق عزله
الحركه ويؤثر على قاتها مع المجتمع الدولي
ناصر شديد الجزيره كابول